before we begin since this is a BBC
owned property I feel the need to point
out that the news armor the BBC has a
continuing issue with transphobic
leanings in its news coverage you can
find in a pinned comment below various
videos from both myself and other
YouTubers covering this issue and while
I understand that the Doctor Who
creative team is not responsible for
this I will continue to point this out
for as long as it remains a consistent
issue thank you
tag
you're it
foreign
[Music]
Jody Whitaker's last episode the final
episode with Chris chibnol as showrunner
possibly the last episode he'll ever
write who knows
but uh it's an ending of a lot and I
come into this
really quite nervous
because knowing how much we were seeing
in the trailers
how much stuff has been left dangling
from previous series up to this point
primarily series 12 but also some from
13 uh or flux however you want to think
of it there's a lot of stuff this is
crammed full this has got three villains
uh set up this has got so many
appearances from older characters that
are coming back most of which
um were not shown in the uh marketing
footage so like it's even more returning
people than you think it's gonna be all
of this stuff just kind of crammed into
one space it is jam-packed with crisis
on top of crisis on top of Bonkers
playing from the master on top of some
very cheap tugging at the heartstrings
kind of stuff and you know what
it actually kind of works
I I'm I'm stunned right now and
it's really difficult to talk about
because
this as an episode
is both a success and a failure as an
episode on its own I actually think it's
very successful
this is pretty good this reminds me of
uh rtd's finales this has that kind of
yes it's a little bit cheesy yes we're
just kind of cramming a bunch of stuff
in but if you can hit the right
emotional notes along the way it still
lands right and this does
but at the same time by the nature of
what it chooses to focus on or kind of
more glaringly all the stuff that it
just opts to not deal with
it kind of highlights a lot of the
failings of chimnal's era overall
so
at a certain point it's probably about
an hour in
when this thing really got its claws
into me
that also required me to accept
that what chibnol had opted to do rather
than try and actually dial back and
properly deal with a bunch of remaining
dangling threads and when I say any
dangling threads I mean stuff like the
Timeless child that has ultimately not
really meant anything stuff like Joe
Martin who still has a ton of questions
to be answered for such as why the heck
was her Tardis even a police box I get
why them oh I'm just gonna go into
spoilers realize this I get why the
Masters is a police box it's a mockery
especially given what his plan is
intended to be why the heck was hers
that why did you set up the whole thing
with the fall boards that it had answers
dropped it into the tartisan we just
that never comes up again are we
actually going to expect Davies to pick
up on that because I wouldn't expect him
to generally it's a matter of wiping the
Slate clean but there's all this stuff
left over is Gallifrey destroyed is it
not all this stuff that should just
decided to not deal with
and on the one hand that is kind of
emblematic of a failure of his tenure
but at the same time for the sake of
this episode on its own
that was almost definitely the right
call
because if this had tried
to actually deal with all the stuff that
had been brought up and not properly
really addressed or felt like it hadn't
gone anywhere yet
then this honestly couldn't have been
its own thing it would have been nothing
but going through a checklist of all
this stuff that he had intended to do
hope to do but couldn't do because of
covid shortened seasons
possibly being forced out of the
position earlier than he wanted we don't
know that's rumored I don't want to get
into the rumor mill but like all these
circumstances that probably kneecapped
his ability to do what he wanted to do
during his time he could either have
spent however long they gave him about
an hour and a half just going through a
checklist of trying to tie stuff off
which would have felt dull and
mechanical and just like oh okay okay oh
okay or
he could throw all that aside except
that he was just flat out not going to
be able to give a satisfying answer or
conclusion to any of them and just focus
on giving us a good episode here and
that is what he did
and you can disagree with that choice
I do think it's the right one under the
circumstances
and with that choice in mind I think he
succeeded
it took me a little bit of time to fully
get into the mindset of accepting that
this wasn't gonna deal with huge swaths
of stuff and so much of this like
especially at this point the Timeless
child seems pointless like it meant
nothing it went nowhere and that in and
of itself does kind of tick me off why'd
you do it if you weren't going to do
anything with it I'm sure he had
something he wanted to do with it he
didn't get the chance to for probably a
multitude of reasons but rather than
give us a cheap lousy condensed
checklist bullet point version of
whatever it was he had tried to do
originally
he gives us this
and as much as I'm going to remain
curious about where he would have wanted
to go with stuff like the Timeless child
or a bunch of the dangling questions
about Joe Martin or whatever
ultimately at the end of the day I'd
rather have this than have those answers
so
I'm actually feeling pretty good right
now
uh I will say the the other thing that I
I suppose I'll note now up front
is that while I do like this episode
quite a bit now I actually think as a
finale it's pretty dang strong I wish it
was the finale of a better run of shows
I wish it was a finale for a better era
but as a finale I actually think it's
pretty good
so
taking that into account I do think that
it's worth my noting it doesn't really
alter too many of my feelings about
Whitaker in the part overall partially
because due to the nature of the story
and what happens with the master and
I'll get into my thoughts on more of
these specifics as I go due to how that
works
Whitaker doesn't get as much of a
highlight as I would have wanted that is
in some ways a little bit of the
sacrifice of what happens when you bring
all this other stuff in you could
actually kind of argue it happened a
little bit to tenant in
um well I would actually say Journey's
End would be a better example he got a
pretty good highlight in say the end of
time but say Journey's End which was a
finale and I feel like a finale that
this is kind of pulling from spiritually
speaking
tenant himself and the 10th doctor does
kind of get sidelined to make room for
everybody else it was more acceptable
there because he'd had a stronger run up
to that point and
um or at least to me it was more
acceptable there whereas here like I
would have liked to feel like because
I've always kind of felt a little bit at
a distance with Whitaker's doctor and
this doesn't really fix that but at this
point it probably nothing could I would
have liked to have had more emphasis on
her had her have more Focus
but again to give her that means cutting
back or removing a whole bunch of other
stuff that I did like so
what do you do and part of the reason I
mentioned this is because I'm gonna have
coming out
um
in a
week
two weeks something like two weeks my
new ranking of all the doctors and the
thing is I've already shot it
um because I went in saying I can't
imagine this last episode was going to
change my opinion of the doctor herself
and ultimately it didn't so you know
neither positive nor negative I feel the
same about her uh now that I did when I
shot that video uh week and a half or so
ago and when it airs in a little bit
from now so
yeah I kind of got on a tangent anyway
let's actually let's actually talk about
this
I'm going all over the place all right
let's focus it up sorry there was a lot
grant me that there was a lot so
let's start with something like the
master dewan's really good in this part
he really is uh kind of nailing what I
feel like John Sim was going for but
didn't work for me especially in Sims
early appearances but this kind of manic
energy he manages to bring in a way that
feels more focused and as kind of yeah
you know antsy and and everything as he
is he doesn't feel uh as cartoonish as
Sim did especially in series three so I
actually really like this that he's able
to give that same energy that Sim gave
when he first started playing the master
but is able to sort of shave off the
edges of that that didn't work for me so
I think he's great in this part and he
has a lot of great little moments he's
got this wonderful little touch of
self-loathing that gets tossed in just
before he he is pulled out of the mat
the not the doctor's body which okay
that's a cool idea too I'm it is one of
those things where like
part of me was like does that fit the
rules except I actually think it
kind of does because like on the one
hand we know about Forester Generations
we know that
um a body can be selected this whole
thing went down with the second doctor
um so we know all of that
I did wonder like but can he like
imprint his personality over hers and
I'm willing to accept it given the
specifics of everything he's channeling
between the Tardis and this cyber
conversion planet and him having you
know I'm just it's made very clear that
he has assembled the tools to do this
and what he's doing is not easy and not
something that like could just be done
for the heck of it this is something
that he had to pull a lot of resources
to pull off and honestly that's enough
for me that I can roll with it and it's
a pretty terrifying idea and he's
downright intimidating especially when
he's with Yaz and he's basically saying
like come with me be my companion and I
love the the mashup outfit that he gets
that he ends up putting on of all the
different doctors you know we'll be
we'll get to that I'll try I'll try and
get to everything
um you know I think I first started to
realize something's a little off about
this but in a good way
um in terms of what I expect from
chiminal when Dan left as early as he
did because part of me was left
wondering okay if you're just not gonna
have him around why even bother with
this little mini adventure and granting
him a good buy from the Tardis with the
same weight you'd normally give someone
like when they leave at the end of a
series or what have you why wouldn't you
just open and he's like already not
there you can like call in and be like I
hope you guys are having fun I'm like
doing whatever except that
this is what channel decided to focus on
he decided to put a focus on the
companions on the people that the doctor
has
um
touch the lives of so actually giving
him a proper send-off even though he is
gone early and for the vast majority of
this
does actually feel right it felt
confusing at first but by the time it's
done I look back and I'm like no
actually that does
that does feel kind of right and that
was sort of like my first hint because
after it happened I was like okay why
did you even bother but then I kept
thinking back to it as the thing was
going along and I was starting to make
that shift into what it was actually
doing
then we've got Tegan and Ace so first of
all
I love how tick Tegan is at the doctor
and rightfully so I'd say and I love all
the layers of complication with Ace
being around the dark I love that they
put her in that jacket and gave her the
back and gave her the Nitro 9 again I
love Ace
so much and I like Tegan a fair bit as
well but Aces she's so good and yeah so
let's talk about the use
of the previous doctors
first of all
props to uh the folks behind this for
keeping all that Under Wraps I imagine
that was probably a heck of a lot more
uh easy to do than the fact that tenant
was going to be uh resuming the role
because you know they had to do exterior
shooting for that and people spotted him
cell phone pictures whatever and
obviously what they have with the older
doctors was all just them you know in a
room with a green screen that that was
easy to keep a lid on keep minimal crew
and you know not have that get out but
boy
when we first saw David Bradley I'm like
oh cool and then Colin Baker
and then Peter Davison and then Paul
McGann and then Sylvester McCoy and I
was already so excited just to see them
and I thought it initially was just
going to be that I like how they they
vary and they bicker a little bit and
again's like I don't do robes and
Mccoy's just oh there's always one
I just the the dynamic of the better
like you need to realize
pretty much all these guys have been
doing like big finish stuff for a while
and some of them to get have done it
together to some degrees so like they're
really good at just taking these little
isolated moments in character and just
delivering them and they can be stitched
together and this and it works really
well and I it's it
stuns me that I was caught off guard
with the whole little
um hologram implanty thing that the
doctor does when the doctor shows up in
front of Tegan and then turns into
Davison I should have called that I
should have seen that coming and I don't
know why I didn't but when it did and
the two of them have their back and
forth where Tina's all like you look
like you but different and and Peter
Davis is like I could say the same to
you and just seeing that interaction
I don't even like Peter Davidson's
doctor all that much but I got
legitimately choked up seeing that
especially when he said Brave heart to
her which I knew that I knew was coming
I knew that line was coming and I still
was like
and then we get to Ace and the volcano
I'm like it's gonna be McCoy it's gonna
be Sylvester McCoy and
there he was and I lost it a little bit
I cried a little bit
chip no
what the hell man
is it a cheap
heartstring tug
yes
will it mean as much to people who art
is invested in classic era and are only
really that deep into modern era
I don't know that's not the perspective
I have but I would imagine probably not
but I also think it was delivered well
enough that you can still get what this
connection between them was like I think
it would still work just not necessarily
as well but tell you what for me
it worked like gangbusters
it was
I it it hit me right because like that
is
that is one of my favorite
doctor companion pairings
is Sylvester McCoy and Ace
Seventh Doctor and Ace Sophie Aura they
are
so good together
and just seeing them I was gonna say in
the same space they're not he's clearly
you know
cgi'd in but like I don't care
it's so good
at least for me it is and then and then
Joe Martin showing up and like again so
many questions we have about the
fugitive doctor that have not been
answered and we're probably gonna have
to turn to big finish to get answers for
and you can definitely and I even would
say chibnol failed in his execution of
that idea in the show proper but you
know what I still had a huge grit on my
face when she walked through that door
because she's awesome and she has a
great presence and I see her there and
she watched some of that confidence and
says I'm the doctor I'm like yes
I don't care that it is failing to pull
together everything that came before by
the time that happened I had detached
from the baggage of this era because
there's a lot of baggage
and if somebody is watching this who
couldn't detach from the baggage or says
it's basically like saying shut your
brain off to uh disregard the baggage of
the era up to this point I'm not even
gonna say you're wrong but I am going to
say that if you can do that I think
you'll find a lot to like here there's
even a bunch of like little ideas along
the way that are really cool and neat
like the idea of a Trader Dalek because
how what the dialects have become is the
Betrayal of the original Mission to
preserve the Khaled race and the fact
that that's not well like it is a trick
in that the Daleks know he's going to
portray them and they're using that
which is actually a pretty clever plan
on their part the fact that he is he
himself is not tricking them he's
sincere in that adolic arrived at that
conclusion on his own that's interesting
that's a neat thing
um bringing back a shot ultimately like
a shot again in terms of the overall era
was still wasted he was an amazing
fascinating aesthetically brilliant
character who was killed
and really shouldn't have been and he
has brought back here but it's a clone
so he's really just there for the visual
and the aesthetic but the visual in the
aesthetic is also part of what's really
strong about him so
you know did that character get used to
his max potential in General's hands no
no he didn't was I still happy to see
him back yeah I was I like that you can
tell just from her performance alone not
without not with having to sink a ton of
time into it that Yaz is thrown off by
meeting Ace and Tegan and being told
they used to travel with the doctor
because we know we now know her feelings
about the doctor so to realize that she
could be discarded that's gonna hit her
and it's not like a totally new idea
that's something that kind of came up
with rose you know way back with the
10th doctor but at the same time like
yeah it would hit her and they don't
dwell on it too much where it feels
completely like a rehash it's
acknowledged just through little bits of
the performance so that gets sold well I
like that the doctor gets called out
well initially by Yaz but then by other
people as well for not sharing things
which has been kind of part of my issue
with the doctor is she is so closed off
it has made her hard to relate to for me
but I like that she gets called out on
that and that gets done well I I like
the the the alien that like looks like
the little girl but it's actually this
energy being it's actually a little bit
lovecraftian in terms of how the thing
actually looks and how weird it is and I
just like that stuff is it super
important no is it a little bit of an
incident incidental detail sure do I
care no because at this point I'm really
just rolling with this thing
and it has not happened nearly as often
as I would like
with this era of the doctor
but there has reliably been
at least one episode
that I was able to key in really well
and be like
how do I wish there was more of this
series 11 it was Take Me Away series 12.
it was can you hear me flux it was war
of the suntarens and with these last few
specials I did really like Eve of the
Daleks but it's this
I was able to key into exactly what this
was doing not immediately as I said but
by a little after the halfway mark I was
keying into it and buy an hour in
I was fully there
and it really just felt good
I always say
I Want to Love Doctor Who every time I
watch anything Doctor Who related New
Classic big finish anything I want to
love it I can't completely shut off my
critical brain it's kind of why I went
off at the beginning at how this fails
to deal with all this lingering stuff I
can't completely shut that off but I can
under the right circumstances at least
put less importance and less emphasis on
and recognize you know what this time I
don't need to dwell on that now I'll
give you a heads up that kind of feeling
has a tendency to result in something
that I enjoy in the moment but don't
think as well on later
um I'm not saying that's necessarily
going to happen here I don't know but
that is this is the kind of piece of
entertainment that can sometimes happen
for me with I have slightly better hopes
for this specific thing though because
as I said this really does feel like
chipmunk made the very deliberate choice
we're not dealing with all the stuff
that I have set up and that I couldn't
get to We are giving a celebratory
large-scale
story
tons of former companions are really
bold idea from the doctor which is just
kind of a more focused take in a way on
his whole uh Master race thing from the
end of time which I know a lot of people
really hate and I don't so like I'm
totally good with that the performances
are good it looks good I feel like the
music got some better highlights here
than it often does like the music of
this era overall is underrated partly
because it's usually used as Ambience
and background it's not bombastic the
way that Murray gold was but that
doesn't make it not good and I feel like
I got some better highlights for it here
and then just the sheer number of people
that seen like just maybe go
I mentioned all the doctors obviously
Tegan obviously Ace but then Mel who I
don't even like
Joe Ian
this
this is
reminding me of what I liked about
Russell's finales
not always necessarily the Regeneration
stories but his finales in general
it's a fireworks display that is also
trying to hit you in the fields at least
a little bit
and sometimes that can be insufficient
but
if he can get it
that works for me
and this actually
shockingly surprisingly at the very very
end of a run of Doctor Who that I have
had
so many issues with
yeah
this worked for me and then of course I
can't not bring up
the very end where the doctor not only
regenerates into tenant but like the
clothing gets replaced which is weird
that's new
um not necessarily something I expect to
get addressed but maybe because we're
already dealing clearly with a very
anomalous regeneration I did call both
of the lines that tenant was going to
have starting with I know these teeth
and then of course what
what
what
I knew that was going to be it
and knowing it didn't make me smile any
less as it happened I do think they need
to be very careful with this and I think
it
I've said in the past that I think is a
terrible idea
to have the doctor regenerate into a
former face
I've gone on record with that
they have now done that
I will say that there is one caveat that
I didn't take into account that is
currently in place that makes me
still nervous about this but certainly
much more okay with it than I would have
been on premise which is that
we know this is for a short run because
we already know who the next Doctor is
after this
and so
being so upfront that this is limited
short time anomalous
while I still don't love that egg
getting cracked of this idea of like
well we've established we can do it I
mean technically they established that
they could do it back in Day of the
Doctor with the great uh curator and
bringing back Tom Baker and just saying
you'll revisit some of the old favorites
so like it's already been established
but now they've actually done it as a
thing for the doctor uh for however many
specials we end up getting I now
strongly suspect that we'll get more
than just the 60th but even if that's
all we get like this is short time and
that's a decent way to do it even though
I I don't I don't don't love that that
Seal's broken
whether or not it was worth it will
depend on what happens so we'll deal
with that when we get there that's also
a great sign off line from
Jody Whitaker
I started with it
tag you're it
that's great
I like that she didn't have to give a
speech
actually
I like that she just
took a quiet moment
with Yaz
with ice cream
and
looking down on the Earth
before saying I I'd rather be alone for
this
I like that she went low-key
because it honestly
would have been weird for this
particular incarnation of the doctor to
do a speech
on the level or in the vein of
something like what the 11th doctor did
or what the 12th doctor did before
regenerating
short
simple
little bit of a speech but just way more
low-key about the whole thing
it fits
it works it is a great button on a very
tumultuous era
like I said if the rest of chimnal's run
had not been
the rest of gypnol's run
this could have been an amazing
final episode
on a great
era but since we haven't had a great era
it stands out as an anomalously good
final episode
and if I'm very lucky I'll get this
review out
uh same day at least same day my time
because people are are already hounding
me like we want to hear your opinion
um maybe it'll end up getting up uh
tomorrow morning I don't know we'll see
how quickly I can uh get this finished
and rendered and everything but I think
there's probably specific stuff that I
am glossing over missed didn't think to
say but just I feel good
I'm feeling a way that I wish I felt
more
during this era during this run
power of the doctor
what did you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments and let's
talk about it
patreon is what pays the bills around
here uh we've had a jump of folks uh
showing up as subscribers lately greatly
appreciated we broke sixty thousand hey
that's awesome if you do want to support
my ability to keep doing that patreon's
the best way to do it but even if you
can't do that like share subscribe they
help me out as well
and what I really want you to remember
is that you are the council
I'm just running the meetings
and until next time
this Council
is adjourned
[Music]
all right time to thank my highest
supporting patrons Robin Moore Zubin
lafolla Tarak the theme that goes joint
in the anime Oliver B Melinda Walters
emudelki Leo the Boyd toy lowly Becky
Sparks for nobelax the poodle Zack
Bookworm Tracy scrabot angry casperal
Adam RDL Taylor Shayla Gourley Brendan
Larose and TT thank you for your support
if you want to hear me try and say your
name while this little guy tries to chew
on my earrings well you can check out
the patreon or the support tears that
get you a shout out thanks so much you
are a pain in my butt
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]